je vous ai vu sourire pascal murs beiges
et j'ai dit le chef du parti québécois
est le chef parlementaire
ouais d'ailleurs on vous pose souvent la
question de ce temps là est ce que vous
regrettez pas un petit peu puisque vous
êtes quand même bien installé j'ai plus
d'ambition pour ma belle région et pour
le québec pour moi même alors ma
priorité c'est toujours été député de
matane matapédia mais je vais demeurer
utile mais j'ai quand même beaucoup de
plaisir assumé cette fonction là eh oui
il arrive que des gens me demandent de
le considérer mais c'est déjà bien
réfléchi bon je vais aller dans le même
ordre que les autres chefs la pandémie
d'abord prenons l'exemple concret des
préposés aux bénéficiaires où il ya un
petit décalage entre le terrain et
l'énoncé les désirs du premier mineur
qu'est ce que ça vous dit mais le
gouvernement plutôt volontaire moi
j'aime ça le premier ministre veut que
ça se fasse
alors ils passent le message que les
gens auront un travail une bonne
rémunération pour les travailler dans le
domaine de la santé puis ne sera pas
facile alors sacrée ça beaucoup de
mouvements beaucoup de gens qui ont
envie de vivre cette expérience de
travail et dans le domaine de la santé
sauf que en ce qu'on nous présente dans
les points de presse de 13 heures et ce
qui se passe réellement dans le réseau
de la santé
il ya un décalage depuis le début de
cette crise entre le volontarisme du
gouvernement du québec et entre les
contraintes du réseau et la capacité de
réaliser les choses alors c'est un
exemple parmi d'autres mots je trouve
que c'est une bonne idée et je souhaite
que le gouvernement du québec que ce
réussir à engager dix mille personnes
qui vont qui vont être présent présent
pour s'occuper de nos aînés mais des
choses à préciser notamment des
conditions de travail semblerait que
déjà même ont quitté leur emploi et le
réalisme savate et et à temps partiel
alors il ya un ajustement à faire et ça
presse
qu'est ce que vous demandez au
gouvernement d'un dunkley revêtent
donner l'heure juste si on a besoin de
temps partiel il faut le dire aux gens
c'est du temps plein il faut le dire
aussi
les gens devront passer d'un ch et celle
des halos il faut le dire parce que
c'est une carrière qui est très
engageante et les gens qui sont sûres
les bains de la formation présentement
besoin de le savoir je pense qu'il faut
jouer
l'honnêteté et puis fuller et rapidement
parce qu'ils sont en début de parcours
et vaut mieux savoir à quoi s'attendre
parce que lorsqu'il sera confronté à des
situations réelles ensemble de soins
longue durée puisque vous en parlez j'ai
passé trois ans avec mon père pas
tellement loin d'ici en attendant intel
sangles c'est si difficile c'est dur et
on voit et on vit des choses
particulières alors dans une situation
comme celle ci en plus parce que donner
l'heure juste à toutes ces personnes
pour l'équipement est touché ce qu'on
est prêt pour la deuxième vague vous
croyez tout est une des questions que je
me suis posée comme parlementaire et
comme citoyen c'est notre degré de
préparation et ça implique aussi la
question des masques et moi en mai
dernier mip
j'ai posé la question est ce qu'on
devrait pas rendre le masque obligatoire
à montréal dans le transport en commun
dans les lieux où il ya une grande
densité de population on va d'abord
distincts dangereux juridique
ça a duré à peu près 24 heures même
joyeuse great d'accord alors là on était
on était en avec une caution
ensuite les masques on disait on en a
pas assez et puis ça va créer un
déséquilibre du second les moyens ceux
qui ont pas les moyens
ben men on réalise que les masques sont
à faible coût et déjà qu s'en fabrique
et on a beaucoup de disponibles et
voudrait que le gouvernement ne veut pas
faire le poids supplémentaire d'avoir
une contrainte de dire de l'imposer et
j'avais vu le tous ces médecins qu'on
connaît bien mais non plus les mêmes
en 2002 un terrain quelques minutes
docteur docteur bon car docteur 4 et ce
en à peu près tout cela et ils disent
aux recteurs la santé publique
c'est ce qu'il faut faire pour se
prémunir d'une deuxième vague et nous le
dit le 13 mai dernier ont été l'objet
d'un peu de railleries du gouvernement
mais finalement je trouve que c'était
l'attitude à avoir alors une grande
décision à prendre mais le gouvernement
du québec monsieur legault nous a dit et
puis à dieppe lors de toutes ces
entrevues de fin de session qu'il ne
rendrait pas le masque obligatoire que
c'était ultime en sa décision qui ne
veut pas le faire qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
ben ça pose aussi la question de caisse
qui relèvent du politique qu'est ce qui
relève la santé publique parce que pour
plusieurs enjeux les ministres disent
savez on n'a pas tellement le choix
c'est la santé publique et dans d'autres
cas c'est le premier ministre qui
tranchent directement vous savez j'ai
posé ces questions là sans arrêt depuis
le début de la pandémie parce qu'il est
important pour moi que mes lui de
connaître les intentions du gouvernement
des élus puisque seuls pas le dr arruda
qui n'est pas un élu je questionne ce
que le gouvernement du québec fait de
ces avis et devrait leur art
tu mets qui devrait le rendre
obligatoire vous dites que monsieur
legault devrait faire le poids
supplémentaire mais dans le transport en
commun puis dans les lieux on est
vraiment le très proches les uns des
autres
parce que oui et les sites je ne veux
pas l'entendre de moi il entendre de
plus les plus éminents médecins
spécialistes de montréal qui lui disent
il me semble que la réponse n'est pas
satisfaisante racisme systémique ou pas
qu'est ce que vous en êtes dans ce débat
là dessus mais c'est une question qui
est chargé un racisme systémique et ça
fait même l'objet de débats dans notre
course au leadership où je dois avoir un
devoir de réserve mais vous connaissez
je vais quand même vous dire quelque
chose je pourrais dire que je m'en
occupe pas mais ça ça m'intéresse
beaucoup cette question là au québec là
il ya du racisme
il y a des gens qui sont des racistes et
pire il ya des gestes racistes alors il
faut combattre le racisme sous toutes
ses formes le racisme points et nous on
est prêts pour ça parce qu'en 2017 en le
déposant un projet de loi qui inclut 20
mesures concrètes pour lutter contre le
racisme dans le domaine de l'emploi
pour ce qui est du logement par exemple
dans l'ensemble des secteurs ces mesures
là les prêts à les mettre en jeu et
j'adore ce convoi collaboré avec le
groupe de parlementaires que mis en
place le premier ministre c'est notre
intention
d'accord mais pas répondu à ce culte
d'après vous il ya du racisme systémique
ou pas c'est pas un terme que j'utilise
ya du racisme et c'est suffisamment
rassembleur pour nous mobiliser pour y
travailler et le racisme c'est pas très
beau et ça mérite d'avoir le plus de
personnes possibles qui vont dans le
même sens
combattons leur faisons également de
l'éducation populaire
c'est un gars chantier collectif quelles
que soient nos origines quelles que
soient nos formations politiques
le québec c'est pour tout le monde et
toutes les personnes qui habitent sur le
territoire du québec sont des québécois
à part si vous avez vous êtes très près
de monsieur legault là vous avez le même
discours que monsieur leubou linverse
sous l'inversé parce qu'on l'a depuis
plusieurs années ce discours étiez vous
étiez et amusant de voir vous êtes
chaque année là au cours de la session
beaucoup par la fin vous n'êtes pas fait
des câlins vrai n'a pas le droit de me
taire je vous respecte je te respecte sa
coque
oui vous avez travaillé avec lui ici on
a gardé de très bons liège aurait une
infection un respect paix de l'âme il si
il y avait et a jeté son stagiaire puis
son conseiller politique ce qui
m'empêche pas d'être très critique à
l'égard sicile ou d'y aller parce que
tellement de piquer ou sort à la cac
je suis indépendantiste je pense que ça
me disqualifie je suis très bien dans ma
formation politique j'ai été élu dans
cette circonscription marc soixante dix
pour cent des employés alors ça me donne
l'énergie est ce que c'est à la course
sera oublié vingt cinq ans j'ai déjà
trop près d'un bon j'ai regardé le débat
conservatoire hier j'ai regardé c'est
pas sa chambre de communes jacques
martin je pense ça va être drôlement
plus intéressant ça va se faire en été
c'est déjà arrivé et on a des candidats
qui sont pas tous pareils j'ai parlé du
racisme systémique sur l'avenir
l'indépendance sur l'environnement sur
pleins dangereux on aurait une belle
course j'invite les gens à devenir
membres pourront voter dans ses courses
soi cet amateur est tous là je suis sur
l'avenue saint jérôme en face de radio
canada gaspésie vizela matin je suis à
cinq minutes de chez moi
pas d'embouteillage cette chance il
vraiment une journée comme aujourd'hui
ça nous est extraordinaire l'air de chez
vous mais refuse on est accueilli
c'est ce que je voulais comme le premier
ça vous a dit moi aussi j'aurai dans
votre cour il arrive ici on est très
accueillant ça se voit
car dieu a dit obama